welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a full recap of
everything you really need to know from
HBO succession seasons one two and three
so that when you ask questions during
season four your roommate doesn't tell
you to off off succession is
about a family-run media conglomerate
with drama inspired directly by
companies like Disney and fox you know
The Gatekeepers who decide everything
else we cover on this channel so let's
break it down in this amount of time
starting with season one we meet the
family matriarch Logan Roy Brian Cox the
crass conservative CEO and chairman of
the fictional way star royco he's based
on figures like Fox News owner Rupert
Murdoch Donald Trump and Shakespeare's
King Lear when you look at his
relationship with his successors his
second son Kendall Roy the amazing
Jeremy Strong is his ambitious Heir
Apparent who's a fascinating Pretender a
bro stick in the mud empty suit
struggling to find an identity of his
own and a history of drug abuse Logan's
eldest son is actually Conor Roy Alan
Ruck and aloof real non-player from
Logan's first marriage living out in New
Mexico Kendall's sister is Siobhan Roy
AKA shiv Sarah snook the name shiv not
an accident because I believe out of all
of her kids she's the most like her
father she's a Cutthroat political
consultant doesn't start the series in
the way star company she's engaged to
Tom wamsganz my favorite character of
the show Matthew McFadden he's really a
pathetic kiss ass company man who goes
on I believe the most interesting Arc of
this series Logan's youngest is Roman
Roy Kieran Culkin who is a walking troll
meme with an edge Lord sense of humor
who does and says everything just to
make everyone in the room uncomfortable
and never sits in a chair normally and
then there's Greg Hurst Nicholas Braun
AKA cousin Greg the grandson of Logan's
estranged brother he stumbles into the
family at the start of the series after
getting fired from the company's theme
park Division and he just keeps falling
upward under the wing of Tom Tom uses
Greg as a punching bag whenever he gets
abused by his wife or the other
members of the Roy family so the series
begins with Logan suffering a stroke
creating a succession crisis among his
kids and among the company and within
the Family Trust with Logan's new wife
Marsha Kendall steps in after pushing
through a deal to buy upstart Balter and
discovers Logan secretly put the company
in debt so Kendall brings in venture
capitalist Stewie who secretly
represents Logan's media rival Sandy
Furness tommywall inherits a crisis of
cover-ups of deaths and sexual assault
in the company's Cruise division so we
enlist Craig to destroy the evidence
over Thanksgiving shiv cheats on Tom
with Nate who has been trying to recruit
shiv to work on the campaign of Gill
Evis a Bernie Sanders type figure
Logan's physical and mental state is
wavering so Kendall tries to oust him
with a vote of no confidence but fails
to secure enough board votes when Roman
cowers to his dad Kendall ends up
relapsing and strikes a deal with Stewie
and Sandy to give Logan what's called a
bear hug a hostile takeover of the
company through a shareholder boat he
tells Logan this on the day of shiv and
Tom's wedding in England and on the
night of the reception Kendall gets high
with a caterer that Logan had fired and
they drive off the road into a river the
caterer drowns Kendall runs pretends
nothing happened but Logan's security
finds Kendall's room key and Logan
blackmails him into dropping out of the
Hostile takeover it's kind of the
craziest thing to happen on the show so
far but it's also based on the real life
events of Ted Kennedy running his car
off a bridge in Chappaquiddick and
leaving his girlfriend a drown this
totally happens and rich people always
get away with it also ship tells Tom
about the affair on their wedding night
and pressures them into an open marriage
on their way tonight on our
wedding night the satellite launched
Roman was overseen it explodes and Conor
with his escort turned girlfriend Willa
the most grounded character we really
get to know on the show freaking Conor
decides to run for president okay in
season two Kindle becomes Logan's
soulless puppet he has to gut his own
prized acquisition of valter and Logan
to give him leverage in the proxy battle
targets rival media giant Pierce a
liberal-leaning Prestige news
organization also run by a family but a
fascinating Bizarro version of the Roy's
they are led by Nan Cherry Jones and Ria
Holly Hunter on a hunting trip Logan
makes Tom Gregg and CFO Carl play Burr
on the floor to find out who leaks stuff
about him to a biographer and it comes
out that Roman went around Logan to
reach out to the Pierce family first
which is embarrassing during this time
Roman and general counsel Jerry begin a
messy sexual relationship where Jerry
advises Roman and demeans him over the
phone as he gets off to it as the head
of the news division Tom is dealing with
their controversial white nationalist
anchor leading to an active shooter
situation in the offices and Greg had
kept some of those papers for that crew
Scandal to use his leverage someday and
he still keeps them even when Tom tries
to burn them shiv bristles with Senator
Gill over waystar's mean new coverage
and quits the campaign to work for the
company after Logan hints that he might
make her CEO but when it's pierced steel
almost comes together Ria is announced
as Logan's successor but at the last
minute this Cruise Scandal breaks and
man exits the deal it's dead in
frustration Logan backhands Roman and it
all comes out that Logan definitely used
to hit Roman there's mysterious scars on
Logan's back as well from his uncle
everyone in his family is abusing each
other in fact we also learn in season
one that Kindle when they were kids
would make Roman eat dog food and stay
in a dog cage for hours yeah it was a
game I had to go climb in this big dog
cage in the kitchen and wait for someone
to come collect me as these two comes to
a close Guild leads Senate hearings
against waystar over the Scandal and
shiv uh persuades a witness not to
testify on the family yacht it's debated
whether Tom or Kendall will take the
fall for the Scandal and Tom confronts
shiv over how miserable he really is in
their marriage Logan picks Kendall to
eat the but during the press
conference Kendall regains his spine and
says Logan knew everything it was all
Logan Greg standing by with the receipts
and Logan watching this on TV looks
oddly proud of his son for coming after
his old man now sometimes when you love
a TV series or a movie it's not enough
to just have been watching it you need
some merch to commemorate the occasion
and nerd riots got you covered if the
finale of The Last of Us left you hungry
for more pick up a lunch of us tea
available in cream or black featuring
the logo of Todd's Steakhouse of episode
8 in the series donate there though just
don't do that unless you're a cannibal
in which case Bon Appetit if you're
stoked for the upcoming John Wick movie
nerd Riot has a whole line of John
Wick's shirts to make you feel like
you've got a seat at the high table
there's the Baba Yaga tea the gun
Chuck's tea and a tea for the high table
itself proclaiming I have served I will
be of service get them now and you'll be
able to wear them to opening night and
then also the next weekend when you see
John Wick chapter 4 for the second time
and of course if you're obsessing over
the Mandalorian right now there's a
whole line of Mando merch in the way
collection with tease beanies hats and
even stuff for kids to get your hands on
the merch you need head to nerd
riot.shop today join the riot over at
nerdriot.shop so then on to season three
Kendall is crazy he hustles to lure his
siblings to join his side but he fails
Logan names Jerry as temporary CEO an
unhinged Kindle keeps crashing company
events Logan pisses off the justice
department leading to an FBI raid of
waystar's offices Tom spends this whole
season preparing for jail time but at
the last minute the government settles
with waystar so Tom has to face his
failing marriage with shiv who signaled
that she didn't want to have kids with
him Greg during this time is pinging
back and forth with Team Kendall and
team Logan his grandfather gives his
inheritance to Greenpeace so Greg takes
the money from Logan and he sues
Greenpeace you're going to sue
Greenpeace
like your style Greg I'm telling you Tom
and Greg this shows true power couple my
favorite relationship on television the
proxy battle escalates to the
shareholder meeting where behind the
scenes Logan suffers from a UTI Sandy
suffers from syphilis neither of them
are really capable of talking so the
Reps end up reaching a deal between the
warring sides they avoid the shareholder
vote then the family Court's Republican
Presidential nominees and settles on
Romans pick neo-fascist Jared Menken
Justin Kirk Kendall throws he completely
over the top 40th birthday party where
Roman meets with eccentric billionaire
Tech leader Lucas metzen Alexander
Skarsgard and Elon Musk figure you could
say he's the founder of Gojo which Logan
wants to buy Roman is running this deal
but then accidentally sends Logan a dick
Pikmin for Jerry leading to this meme
we're all in Tuscany Logan's second wife
Kendall and chips and Roman's mom
Caroline remarries everyone's there
Caroline super toxic tells shiv that she
never wanted to have kids and tell shiv
not to have kids Kendall's in a weird
State and offers to sell his full stake
in the company for two billion dollars
just to leave Logan's life forever and
Logan refuses and Kendall nearly drowns
in the pool recovering he confesses the
caterer incident to Roman and shiv the
three kids are united now and they move
against Logan claiming veto power from
Logan and Caroline's divorce settlement
but Schiff tells Tom this and Tom who's
burned by for telling him that she
didn't love him during foreplay he goes
to Logan and Logan at the last second
renegotiates with Caroline leaving the
kids Iced Out we in season three with
Tom finally having gained the upper hand
on his wife thrilled to be the Nero and
Greg to be his Forest this forest was
Nero sex sleep whom he castrated to make
a woman out of him and in the final shot
of the Season shiv clutches her abdomen
and the three siblings recreate the shot
composition of Kendall's earlier
confession this show is so freaking good
and I didn't even have time to get into
the amazing cinematography the blocking
the writing the acting
theme music of the show that make this
messy soap opera the best show on TV
right now with its finger to the pulse
of our media and political ecosystem I
don't know how they are pulling this off
so well I would love to break down the
episodes of this final season but full
transparency if not enough of you are
watching the show or really want our
coverage if I already tried to do
breakdowns of it the rest of new rock
stars would make we play bore on the
floor every Monday there's just plenty
of other stuff we're excited to cover at
new rockstars too so based on whatever
views this video gets if it's not enough
instead I'll just gush about this show
and it's amazing Easter eggs over on
Twitter you can follow me on Instagram
Twitter at EA bus you follow new
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
foreign
[Music]